hello freak bitches you don't think of
that as being a stress like they think
of stress as being bills they think of
stress as being traffic no stresses
every all those things are stressed
relationships friendships work conflict
when you're at work all day and you hate
your job
that's stress that is stress that grinds
on you yeah that feeling like when you
get out of work at the end of the day
and you have that weight lifted off your
shoulders that means you're in a bad job
you got to figure out a way where you
don't have that if it's possible if it's
possible fine that way that was me ten
years ago I was a municipal tax assessor
in state of New Jersey amazed it was the
just saying all those things together
make me want to fucking jump off for
dude on Friday
I would literally get depressed on
Friday because I knew Monday was coming
yeah I know that feeling it was fucking
it was goddamn hell but I was making a
shitload of money my mom was so proud of
me I had the 401k in the six weeks off
vacation I was living quote the American
dream I fucking hated myself i sat
around I remember this is a turning
point for me i sat around a boardroom
table and I was a lot younger than my
closest peer I'm looking at all these
older dudes and we're all sitting there
in suits and like we're so fucking
important you know being those dickheads
and they're all over waiting they're all
they all have red faces and they're all
talking about how they're gonna fucking
you know sneak off to the bar before
they go home because they don't wanna
deal with the fucking family in the kids
and all the fucking bullshit I did it
fuck out here I have to get the fuck out
of here or I'm gonna fucking die like
this I gotta change my life and that's
what we did and I kind of threw that
away resign from the position took the
job as the strength coach team quest up
in a Portland Oregon moved across the
country for fucking minimum-wage to
clean toilets and left that job behind
and I fucking loved it I loved scrubbing
disgusting shitty gym mats at five
o'clock in the morning and not sitting
in a beautiful corner office you know
for X amount of dollars per year because
I was I was doing what I love and I gave
myself the opportunity and a chance you
know to do something with my life and
get literate of the stress I think
that's why I'm kind of you know veering
well if that's what it was talking I was
so stressed out yeah how's riding my
bike fuck I remember it was freezing
cold fucking raining and I'm riding my
fucking stupid bike because we won
vehicle yeah my wife had to go fucking
work I'm riding my fucking bike six
miles to the gym and I fucking loved it
it was such a pure crisp cold morning
and I was just so alive in life you know
and it was everything was brand new
again I was in my mid-twenties at that
point made later 20s at that point
fucking cool shit man but he gave me the
best advice ever that ever got in comedy
and I talk about this in my act a little
bit like I tell the story but we were
hanging out after we did a show one
night in Cleveland at the at this big
amphitheater and after the show I'm
talking to these two girls you know like
you're so funny and I'm like what you
come back to the hoedown come hang out
Dave might stop by you know pick up
these chick he was gonna stop by though
imagine if you were in the middle of
boning her and she heard Dave's voice
just like get off me yeah exactly
so imagine he's cock-block anybody still
in the living room I'm Rick James bitch
oh my god is it him I need to meet him
he's not going anywhere
I'm come in 30 seconds he was so awesome
no rape he was an awesome wingman cuz he
was he was he's married right and he was
like a great dude about it he was just
like you know he would sit there and
like talk to you you know with the
chicks and then like he'd peel off and
then you'd be there with the checks man
it was fucking beautiful the chicks
would go you must be special oh dude
well they also just saw you open to it
it was so look at you you're close
really it was nice it was really nice so
I'm starting these two girls after one
of the shows in Cleveland and uh and I'm
like come back to the hotel and they're
being wishy-washy and I'm like all right
whatever and they take my number and I
go backstage and I'm bitching to Dave
and the the tour bus driver about these
chicks and I'm like you know they
fucking just being on wishy-washy and I
don't know this I don't know it's just
annoying just fucking hang out if you're
gonna hang out and the bus driver goes
Joe I'm gonna tell you what you need to
do man you need to walk up to that girl
look her dead in the eye and say do you
want to suck my dick or nothing okay and
I was like terrible advice I was like
okay okay and and I was considering it
for a second and then Chappelle goes
don't do that shit man
don't do it you're gonna fuck around Joe
you're gonna get famous one of these
days ten years from now that bitch will
be on hard copy Joe DeRosa told me to
suck his dick in Cleveland once and
that's it that's how I grew up I mean
mmm I would go out a lot of times during
school and I'd just go up and sleep on
the mountain come back do chores milk
cows go to school you know go to
football practice go home do chores go
up on the mountain and sleep on the
mountain come back home I mean that was
kind of how how old my brothers and I
grew up and it's just I mean I just have
a yearning for the wild I mean there's
some of the coolest experiences that
I've had in life have been when I'm by
myself and go and do something just so
totally random that that nobody else
would really even think about I say shit
I shouldn't say nobody but it's like you
know in college I'd drive home two hours
to my folks house and I'd drive another
hour up to the canyon by the time I get
to the trailhead it's 11 o'clock at
night hike in for three or four hours
find somewhere sleep get up on top of
the mountain and I'm sitting there as
the sun's coming up and three Wolverines
come up you know and circle the lake and
it's like back then you know and then in
the 90s there weren't Wolverines in
Idaho they weren't supposed to be anyway
I mean I was one of the very first or
very few to actually see wild Wolverines
in Idaho and it's like had I not been
there by myself experiencing that in
that Canyon you know if there's other
people or other things those Wolverines
might not have been as comfortable you
know but because I was there by myself
and I'm the only one there looking down
over it I had that experience and
there's there's a lot of opportunities
like that that when you have someone
else there you're focused on the group
you're focused on your conversations
your buddies your friends and everything
you're not you're not really tuned in to
what's around you you're not tuned in to
your surroundings and so there's certain
things that I think you miss out on when
you've got other people there and that's
not that I don't enjoy that sometimes
but I feel like when I'm there like
there's a connection you know there's a
connection to the land there's a
connection to the environment and you
know you could bring all of into if
you're if you're a hippie you know tree
hugger voodoo type of person you bring
in the nature and the gods and all that
kind of stuff into the whole element but
that really and truly is what is what it
is is you're out there
with no one but yourself and God in his
creation I mean that's it it's all
surrounding you yeah and being like that
deep in nature where you're actually a
part of it because you're not you're not
talking to anyone so there's no there's
no conversations going on plenty of
conversations just with myself yeah but
you don't I'm saying it's like you don't
there's nothing no anchor that brings
you back to civilization you're just
seeing wild shit you're just seeing
wildlife you're seeing animals that
would exist that way regardless of
whether or not you're there or not